there are very few people left in public
life who i think
represent that old idea of what it means
to be an american what a
american what it means to be a man what
it means to be a
person living in civilization
with the desires and the attitude that
helped us
get to where we are right now one of
those guys that one of those guys who
gives me hope
is elon musk elon musk
who wants to build a bunch of crazy cars
and wants to send people to mars
and wants to half the time i don't know
if the guy's a monorail salesman like in
the simpsons you know if he's like
totally full of it
or if he can actually bring the goods
and it actually seems like he delivers a
lot of the time
elon musk was just asking about this
trip to mars or rather he was asked by
an interviewer about this trip to mars
and it seems like there's some
logistical issues right now right we can
i mean we can't even build a a railway
in california anymore
we're gonna have a super rail connecting
all the parts of california
now it ends up being this tiny little
railway between two towns that nobody
even goes to
we can't do it because that's too hard
it costs too much it's too dangerous
let's do this let's do that
so elon is asking okay how are you
supposed to get to mars and he says oh
well it's going to be extremely
dangerous and unpleasant and a bunch of
people are going to die
go to mars reads like that book for
shackleton going to the antarctic
you know it's it's dangerous uh it's
uncomfortable
it's a long journey you might not you
know come back alive
um but it's a glorious adventure and
it'll be amazing an amazing experience
and your name will go in history yes
you might be uncomfortable and then you
probably won't have good food and
all these things you know so if
if an arduous and dangerous journey
where you may not come back alive um but
it's a glorious adventure
sounds appealing and mars is the place
and you still have
thousands of volunteers if not millions
of volunteers who would want to go
i mean honestly a bunch of people
probably will die in the beginning it's
it's tough sledding over there we're an
exploring species
yeah yeah exactly not forever we don't
make anyone go so it's
volunteers only he's totally right he's
getting a bunch of negative headlines
right now you're saying elon musk is
laughing about people dying
and exploration a lot of people are
gonna die
when we try to colonize mars if if we
ever do that
that's just what happens when the
mayflower landed
in new england and this was well into
the age of exploration it's not as
though they were the first guys to check
out america
when they landed in new england half of
them died within the winter
right this is what happens when you go
to foreign places and you explore
it's arduous it's tough and you're gonna
die and what elon is showing us right
now
is that there is a way of living that is
very different than the way that we're
living in now
right now it seems that most people are
living to craft
a perfectly pleasant and ultimately
meaningless existence
that is what connects all of these
various things the complaints about
grievance the demands for more gut money
from the government the the demands to
be coddled by big technology
the the demands that we pretend that
caitlyn jenner is a woman
and that we indulge everybody in their
fantasies what this is about
is saying look there's no real meaning
in the world there's no objective truth
there's no
there's no objective anything that we
ought to do we just want to
feel good in this very
elementary way in this very childish way
we just kind of want to feel good and so
whatever is going to make us feel good
that's what we should do very often this
is described as the moral maxim of our
era if it feels good do it and you see
it across all sorts of policy
that idea that decadent and hedonistic
idea
is not what built the west it's what is
destroying the west but it's not what
built the west
the idea that built the west is that
there is objective truth
there is objective reality there are
unexplored
lands we want to know things in order to
know things you need to acknowledge that
there's an objective reality that you
can know about
and that there is more to life than
feeling
really pleasant all the time there is
more to life than just
extending your life so much the whole
public discourse of the past year is
about how we can avoid getting a cough
it's about ultimately how we can avoid
death
even if you're very very old even if
you're very very sick
how you can avoid because death is
unacceptable how we can pretend that
we're never going to die
we didn't used to live just to avoid
death we used to accept that we're all
going to die and we're going to die soon
and i'm not not saying tomorrow
necessarily though you might
but i don't you're gonna let's say you
die in 30 years
40 years let's say you die in 70 years
it's not that much time
so if you're if you're going to live
just to not die
you're going to be disappointed you're
going to lose that battle you're going
to have a tragic ending
if you're going to live for something
else if you think that there's more to
life than just
breathing then you could have a great
glorious adventure
like elon musk is saying or
you could deny all of the hard
facts about the world you could deny
that you're going to die you could deny
that you're a man because you want to be
something else
do we want to live in reality or do we
want to live
in delusion do we want to do something
with this life
that we've been given or do we just want
to make ourselves feel good every so
often
which by the way you're not that doesn't
last forever it's like
it's like doing a drug you might feel
good briefly but you're going to have a
hangover you're going to have the
withdrawal you're going to have the
addiction if what's the line from c.s
lewis i mentioned this on tim poole's
podcast
if you look for truth you might find
comfort in the end but if you look for
comfort you'll find neither truth nor
comfort
only soft soap and wishful thinking to
begin and in the end
despair so don't despair look for
something
else hey wait a second don't go anywhere
i've had you know i've had some people
write into me and they say michael
for some reason i'm not getting
notifications for your show
hey michael for some reason even when i
search for your show the videos aren't
always popping up
yeah i think it's because our overlords
don't
love us necessarily in this big tech
space
make sure you smash that button you like
you subscribe
you do everything in your power to get
those notifications you still probably
won't get them but it'll give you a
better chance
of not missing a single video